this is Startalk been odd 3 on Twitter
Gavin said I wasn't given Twitter any
love so let's go to Twitter here's what
he says people emphasize negative
aspects of climate change but are there
any foreseeable positives hmm let me
give you one please so so I'm English
and do you know yes yes yes where where
we hang out all the time at the palace
and and for many years many years you
know there were there was such a thing
as English wine and there was an old
joke in Victoria English wine yes in the
Victorian period that it would take for
people to drink English wine one to
drink the wine two people to hold the
person down and another person to pour
it into the throat ah very troubling yes
okay but now it turns out that there are
more vineyards in in England than there
are ever been in history and in fact
that the sample over 500 yes that we
have we have records of vineyards in
England going back to the Doomsday Book
over a thousand years ago but there's
more now and the wine they're producing
in blind tastings against champagne
actually wins so so wine quality in
England is actually now on a par with
the best of the French can produce
either good French people are gonna be
unglued about that absolutely so so in
fact the champagne companies are buying
up swaths of we're called the South
Downs in in the UK because they know
that the temperatures in champagne are
now at the limit so if it gets much
warmer in Champagne region they won't be
able to make as good champagne there and
they're thinking about moving their
production to the UK so they there will
be a foreseeable benefit for English
wine drink news okay is a little cool
yes it's a little bit further north but
it's very similar soils very similar
terroir and now it's it's actually
happening so there's your answer
Benjamin the positive will
you get to piss off French winemakers
what it means but it writ large is
agriculture is going to change that's
exactly right so you're seeing the same
thing in the US right so Napa Valley
where we're producing a lot of great
wine now is the limit of how hard it
needs to be if it gets much harder it's
going to be harder so production is
moving to Oregon or Washington State
there's some excellent excellent wines
that are really emerging there and
that's part of and British Columbia even
yes so I mean I tasted wines in British
Columbia maybe 20 years ago and the same
joke would have been true there but now
they're actually there are so
agriculture is going to change the whole
problem everybody the way I see it is
it's how fast it's changing we have an
interstate highway system we have trains
in Britain for carrying produce to
market or carrying produce to the the
winery where you're gonna make the
grapes into wine for example or the oats
and oat me or what have you but we're
not set up to have that's all that
production move farther and farther
north or farther and farther from the
equator and rain patterns are changing I
mean nice things like vineyards you know
they're pretty much on the ball and so
there they they pay attention to these
things and move things along quite
quickly but your bigger problem is is
the staples not not the luxury goods you
know wheat corn barley
soybeans all of those things are
affected by better known as food for
most of the world straight-up food this
is Startalk